[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
carson palmer iceman trophy winner at
usc former nfl quarterback
his appearance brought to you by our
partner level select cbd looking for
your next level relief visit
levelselectcbd.com
let me start with the rams in uh matthew
stafford last night could it have gone
any better for matthew stafford
no it was great to see him in a
different uniform surrounded by a ton of
talent uh obviously a great coach on his
sideline and
i think we'll continue to see him
flourish as the season moves moves
forward and we see him to get more and
more comfortable with those guys around
him but you also have a quarterback who
didn't have talent in detroit like how
much can we put on matthew stafford with
the failures of the lions because we're
going to give him a lot of credit with
the rams because he has talent but the
quarterback gets too much credit and too
much blame
true but at the same time i think the
quarterback position is is
really a
it's so important to have the right
organization surrounding you there's
been plenty of quarterbacks that have
gone to the right place and had much
better careers
uh
in the right place the right
organization than them going to a bad
organization like detroit i mean
detroit's been struggling for a long
time
you know we we've heard the stories you
know inside and out from back in the
days
um you know and stafford was there for
12 years he gave it his best shot
he had some talent around him at times
but you know seeing him in la with that
kind of offense that kind of um that
kind of system and and you know there
was a lot of talk about him not being
able to play the game outside the pocket
and do all the bootlegs and play action
stuff that they did but man he looked
good last night getting outside the
pocket and throwing thrown on the run
but these rookie quarterbacks come in
and they're ready to go
um
or at least we think they are but but
the mental part of this though carson
i'm curious about because you sat your
first year behind john kitna but like
physically were you more ready
than mentally or maybe the other way
around
well these guys are coming into the
league physically ready i mean these
these are you know look at trey lance
and in san francisco i mean physically
gifted quick fast explosive arm accurate
but it just takes some time i mean it
just takes that
um you know a couple a couple seasons of
getting used to being on third down
third and long backed up in your own
territory in the red zone with the game
on the line there's so many things that
you need as a quarterback to develop and
and a majority of those things you need
outside of having a great organization
and a really good play caller is
experience and until these young guys
have experience and a bunch of plays and
a bunch of different situations under
their belt they're not completely
mentally ready but these guys are coming
in the league right now physically ready
without a doubt
how overwhelmed did you feel
first year starting
well i had that first year to sit and
rest so i i didn't feel overwhelmed but
had i played in that week one game my
rookie year
um you know i absolutely would have felt
overwhelmed and there's so much you
don't know about this game
um and like i said it just takes reps
and it takes experience
yeah and i'm always curious about that
then you have a bad game and then
it stays with like the pros are able the
veterans can move on like you have to
have a short memory it feels like but it
feels like a rookie
is gonna hold on to that bad
interception he had or a bad loss a
little bit longer
absolutely i mean until you've proven
yourself to your teammates that you can
get over a bad loss a bad play that lost
a game um until you can prove that to
your teammates and yourself you don't
know i mean you you if you can go to
college like kyle murray did at oklahoma
in one year go out there and play
amazing and win a heisman trophy and
almost national championship but until
you do it at the nfl level until you
prove it to yourself hey i can go out in
week one and lay an egg and i can bounce
back in week two and have a 110 passer
rating you know you don't know you can
do it until you do it and you're seeing
some of these young guys struggle i mean
you watch trevor lawrence play yesterday
and it was a struggle but that kid has
the right mentality the right makeup i
expect him to bounce back it might not
be in week two it might not be in week
three
but i would pretty much
take any bet right now saying that
trevor lawrence is not going to be a
bust he will be a successful nfl
quarterback how do you explain aaron
rodgers yesterday
man this this position even when you're
aaron rodgers the position of
quarterback is so difficult
when you put extra pressure on yourself
i mean aaron has aaron has asked for all
the pressure all the criticism you could
possibly ever ask for
and it is so difficult even when you're
as talented and gifted as aaron there's
a lot of pressure on him to succeed
there's a lot of pressure on him to
perform
it just goes to show you that even aaron
rodgers can get round he looked rattled
from the jump i mean he looked like he
was uncomfortable he couldn't settle in
and find his feet he was harassed all
day in the pocket and that might be a
little bit of this off season catching
up to him there's no doubt in my mind
aaron will bounce back and have a pro
bowl tight caliber year no doubt about
it but he looked extremely rattled
yesterday how do you explain patrick
mahomes to those who might not have
witnessed patrick mahomes he's magic he
there's a couple of guys in the league
they are just magicians um russell
wilson jumps out at you know jumps out
the top of my mind he just does things
that you don't expect him to be able to
do
patrick mahomes as much as we think he's
great he's got this big arm and he's
houdini he just makes some plays that we
didn't even think he could make
um but but there's just a handful of
guys in this league right now that have
magic about and he's one of them talking
to carson palmer former nfl quarterback
and of course heisman trophy winner are
gloves performance enhancing
absolutely not for a wide receiver
no i mean
they're uh
you know when i think of performance
enhancing i think like everybody else
you think of something you're injecting
or ingesting some in some form or
another but if putting on gloves
is performance enhancing then so are
shoulder pads and helmets well but it
helps you catch the ball
yeah and uh and a pair of shoulder pads
help you tackle somebody yeah but but
but a previous generation didn't have
this
well the previous generation didn't have
the technology in their helmets and
their shoulder pads that we have to
today
how much does that help having that
technology in your helmet when you have
somebody who can calm you down whisper
to you while you're getting ready to
call your play or getting up to the line
of scrimmage well you don't have that
much time to to have a shrink jump on
your headset and calm you down and talk
you only got 25 seconds you got to get
the play in you got to relay the play
and then get the snap off but
um you know i do think you know that
technology is great because especially
as i got older in the league i was way
too fat and out of shape to run from the
huddle to the sideline and back and
forth in between every play get into
play so i needed that break to stand in
the huddle and hear it through my
headset do you need to be in shape to be
a quarterback
absolutely absolutely unlike pitchers
i've always heard people say that
pitchers have to be in great great shape
to be a pitcher i think you got to be in
even better shape to play quarterback in
the nfl
did you not lift did you not run like
what happened that you got fat
i got old
i shouldn't have said fat i just got old
and i got tired and and all those hits
start adding up having to go back and
forth and shuttle plays in and out when
i was 20 22 23
would have been a lot easier than when i
was 38 so thankfully when i was in my
late 30s i had that headset on you ever
call a timeout because you're too tired
absolutely i actually i got to the
bottom
i got to the bottom of a
scrum and and it was a fumbled snap and
i had gotten back down on top of it
everybody was laying on top of me and i
was i was playing for bruce aaron's in
arizona and i was holding onto the ball
so tightly and somebody from the
opposing team was trying to rip it out
of my hands that my hand went numb and i
was worried that the next player was
going to be a pass and sure enough bruce
called a pass
and my the feeling hadn't come back in
my hands yet because it was so fatigued
for holding on to a ball and trying to
maintain possession at the bottom of a
pile i had to call a timeout
what's it like having aryans talk to you
it's great i mean you look at tampa bay
play now and and brady doesn't have to
deal with aryan's mf and him in the in
the huddle and and over the headset
because he's got byron left which the
offensive coordinator coordinator
calling the plays wait aryans is mf'ing
you
while he's your offensive
all game long
me or the ref or somebody on the
opposing team
you know he would hit that button on his
recorder
and half of what he said was the play
the other half was him mf and the ref or
maybe me from the previous play or
somebody on the other sideline but now
that now that you know he can just you
know coach the game and handle
everything from the 40 000 foot level
and byron left which is calling plays he
seems like his bro his blood pressure's
dropped and he just seems like he's in a
happier place
but how does that
i mean brady wanted to play with bruce
arians do you understand why he would
100 i mean any any pocket passer would
absolutely love that system there's a
ton you watch brady play the other night
on thursday
they're in empty it seems like a quarter
of the game they're just spreading
people out they're getting their best
receivers on the field and they're
letting tom brady do what he does best
which is take his time and take his take
his check downs you know take the
completions and throw the big plays when
they show up
but what's he do better than you
brady yeah
everything no he doesn't do everything
better than you
he does he does uh september 13th 2021
but you know i think the one thing you
you watched that um that last drive they
had where they went down the field and
the one thing brady does in two
two-minute drills is he knows defenses
are scared of him and he takes and lets
the defense get a ton of depth and
create cushion i mean you watch that
last drive where they went down and
kicked the field goal he didn't throw a
ball over 10 yards he just was dinking
and dunking it and the defense was
backpedaling and getting depth and
giving them cushion and he was just
throwing the ball to the running backs
and the tight ends they would step out
of bounds after an eight-yard gain it's
the same thing we've we've seen brady do
in new england for years he doesn't get
rattled he doesn't take chances and try
to force the ball downfield he takes
what the defense gives him and they end
up with a with you know seemingly easy
drive at the end of the game for a field
goal and win
is brady what four years older than you
brady is three years old he's 44 41.
it blows my mind saying that
it's crazy
how long would it take for you to get
ready to play in a game
i mean i could walk out and play in a
game but just as quickly as i walked in
i'd be walking off the field with a
hamstring
shoulder or something i'm in no form to
play right now who was the toughest
quarterback you've faced
well i never beat brady i was up uh i
played against brady a bunch i was up
21-0 uh in the first half in new england
and richard seymour took a low shot on
me and and blew my almost blew my knee
out and i didn't end up finishing the
game but we were up 21-0 so i've beat
brady for a half that's my best game
because i beat brady for half of the
game but do you say this to your kids
like do you say you know dad
dad owned brady for one half
i was driving home uh i was i coached my
my kids seventh grade football team and
i was driving home half the kids that
live up by us and i was dropping them
off and
we're driving along and
one of the kids in the back seat told me
that
his second uncle which i don't even know
what a second uncle is his second uncle
tackled tom brady in college one time
and it really just it really just made
me how much you know made me realize how
little these kids think of me i'm their
coach
they're less than i played in the nfl
they're all out there and russell wilson
jerseys and scatter seahawks gear and
they talk about brady all the time it
drives me nuts they do know you played
in the nfl for 15 years
yeah but it's just like it was just such
a blip on their radar they couldn't wait
to talk about russell wilson and letting
russ cook and tom brady i don't even
think they really realized or registered
to him uh how's your usc trojans
it was a tough one that was a tough one
um
you know it's it's to see the stadium
half full to see it you know us being 17
point favorites and really get blood i
mean it really wasn't a close game
we were totally i mean there were so
many penalties and so so such a lack of
discipline
uh it's really really frustrating to
watch those guys play this last weekend
but the good thing is this week two
we've got a lot of football left did you
uh you lost to stanford on a last second
play didn't you
ah that was a long time ago dan i'm shh
oh i did that's right i lost to chris
lewis they threw a um
a smash concept and they hit the corner
at the end of the game for a touchdown
in the last second that's right good
memory
yeah i'm trying to bring up positives
here i'm sorry it feels like i'm
bringing up negatives but you own tom
brady for one half
21 nothing yeah yeah you always have
that over him
i'm sure he remembers that too hey great
to talk to you thanks for joining us bud
thanks dan that's uh carson palmer
brought to you by a cbd level select cbd
uh provides target relief and helps
treat everyday discomfort when you need
it the most uh this is great it's a
great product
levelselectcbd.com promo code dp 30 30
off your entire order today not
available in idaho iowa and south dakota